[Music]
please tell the world what is going on
with this project that piece is raised
on the right and Briana's gonna be in
and you're gonna be and what is the
status of that is that happening
should we look forward to something what
I will say is that I don't know what
that's it people are going crazy about I
mean it would you know what's really
cool is that people spoke up about the
kind of movie they want to see and this
is a great example like Black Panther is
being embraced because people are really
hungry for this kind of film and that
movie with me and Rihanna and ISA and
Ava is another one of those examples
where people want to see something like
themselves and something different
something they're not being offering it
offered yet and I'm honored to be a part
of that conversation
enough said what was it like being in
there finally seeing the movie seeing
the reception that this movie got it was
astounding actually you know it's so
good to be here at Comic Con with like
the core group of fans that make all
this possible to begin with and then to
have something this year to offer them
and something that even we hadn't seen
was really exciting and then to sit
there and like be blown away but work
that we did and to see what Ryan and the
editing crew are doing with it and the
reception of the audience is so hyped I
mean it just feels so good I wasn't
working with Michael and Chadwick and I
heard they you know they're ripped in
this movie they they bring their sexy to
this meeting oh we all do
no we really worked hard this film was
like about you know the story was
something that was really important to
all of us and we needed to get our
bodies ready for it so our workouts were
extremely worked out together so I saw
some of this some of the muscle being
built around me it was a lot of
different martial arts but to see
everyone start from like being real
clumsy to actually perfecting it was so
cool